la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
Charon merci monsieur le Président je
demande la parole pour un rappel au
règlement dans la nuit du 13 au 14 mai
de graves incidents ont entaché la fait
que Paris attendait depuis 19 ans grâce
à la victoire du PSG ces débordement
ultra violents n'ont pas su être
anticipé ni même géré alors qu'une mise
à sac des champs éélysées avait déjà eu
lieu la veille cette gestion calamiteuse
des violences qui ont déferlé sur la
capitale n'est malheureusement pas sans
rappeler l'incompétence dont avait déjà
fait preuve le préfet de police Bernard
bouot à l'occasion d'une manifestation
familiale et non violente contre le
mariage pour tous certains élus
socialistes ont osé parler de
récupération devant les réactions d'élut
parisiens je les invite à aller
expliquer leur vision des choses au tour
dont l'autocar a été pris d'assaut comme
une diligence je les invite à aller
expliquer aux commerçants qui ont été
attaqués pillé menacés et dont les
magasins ont été saccagés qu'il ne faut
pas en faire une histoire la presse
internationale regarde interloquer le
spectacle de la violence qui déferle sur
Paris je demande donc au ministre de
l'Intérieur manuel Vals de prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent pour que les
futures manifestations
notamment celle du 26 mai soit géré par
un préfet de police professionnel et pas
en prèetraite soucieux du respect du
droit de manifester et de la sécurité
des
Parisiens merci mon cher collèg donné de
votre
déclaration